alors didier barbelivien on t'appelle
monsieur tube ouais ça l'a écrit combien
à peu près dans la presse ça arrive
non c'est pas ce que c'est que de faire
un tube c'est très trop facile parce que
j'ai dû écrire 2000 chansons dans ma vie
et on a 30 qu'on connaît vraiment quoi
ou 20 tu es qu elle m'oublie pour johnny
c'est bien ça ouais il ya dix ans voilà
le mot glissé une belle chanson c'est
vrai que tu l'as fait en dix minutes
celle-là 25 minutes 25 minutes tu penses
qu est ce qu il a fait johnny hallyday
crda gillet et david l'avenir à grasse
un bel album ah non non a dit ce que
tout le monde maintenant je dit pas du
bien tout le monde mais c'est d'abord
moi j'adore johnny hallyday j'avais
regardé gilles tu me prends pas dire du
mal ni de l'un ni de l'autre
et je trouve que c'est un beau disque
par contre y'a un truc de toi qui est
absolument insupportable en ce moment tu
le sais si je te survivrai non moi je
trouve pas non c'est ton client
maintenant s'il va c'est pas mon client
non non c'est pas pour ça que je dis ça
et julien clerc et a déçu tu dis par
rapport à ce qui faisait au début avec
maurice vallet avec roda gil public
aujourd'hui quand on entend la fille aux
bas nylon c'est pas comme quand on
entend la cavalerie ouais t'as lu ça
mais parce que je suis un âne et un
immense fan de julien clerc c'est pour
ça que moi j'ai tellement aimé ivanovic
sous les fleurs des gares où la petite
sorcière malades ou ian et les dauphins
que je trouve que ça s'est un peu
banalisé dans les mots quoi encore que
bon il est fait des trucs avec d'abedi
qui était très très beau mais moi
j'étais un grand fan de la combinaison
maurice vallet roda-gil dans le livre y
revenir à cette combinaison obama et moi
je serais lui je l'aurais jamais quitté
même je veux dire à moi si j'avais eu en
tant qu'interprète des auteurs comme
etienne et maurice quoi je continuerai
de chanter leurs textes sur la lane pas
trop non plus un avis que c'était un
apprenti léo ferré ouais ouais t'es bien
renseigné j'ai 10 h lourde qu'en télé 7
jours mais c'était un peu [ __ ] pour
lui mais après j'ai rencontré le type il
est plutôt sympa francis lalanne mai
mais tous côtés tu fais gaffe qui frappe
en plus il est frappé par il attrapé un
man il s'est pas défendu mais je sais
pas non mais se trouve le côté un peu
peace and love avec deux publics -
sorbon plein fouet
comment tu fais pour écrire des chansons
de faire des trucs par exemple la mer
les lilas c'est des trucs qui reviennent
souvent dans telle chanson dans way sli
la maison chanson c'est ouais c'est pas
des trucs c'est plutôt des tic c'est à
la limite c'est plutôt des mauvais truc
ça c'est tous des choses énervante tiers
quand on te fait remarquer on y met
mais moi je m'en rends pas compte il ya
des gens qui lisent bien j'étais sûr que
c'était toi parce qu'il y avait dit la
maison quais de gares et trains de nuit
tu dis que oui mais à la place de
l'interprète
je rentre complètement tu te moules dans
l'imaginaire de l'interprète chez ça
s'est fait assez compréhensive ouais
c'est également dans ce cas par exemple
à l'interprète comme jean pierre
françois tu te moules dans l'imaginaire
de chanter à françois tu sers à la sir
section pierre françois
mais non les c'est vrai par exemple tu
va le découvrir dans le nouveau 45,6 il
y en a eu et a encore un troisième but
non mais c'est il faut essayer enfin
pour les gens qui n'écrivent pas moi
j'essaie qui me racontent leur vie leur
histoire essayer de deviner ce qui
traduirait 6 écrivait des chansons c'est
ça qui est intéressant je les fais pour
patricia kaas et tu vois ça s'est bien
passé
très bien mais alors est-ce que c'est à
force de te moulé comme salon des
imaginaires tel celui de son père
françois que tu as décidé de faire une
carrière solo parce que ton pouvait plus
parce que tu d'un seul coup tu non pas
du tout c'est marrant que j'aime bien je
cherche pas vraiment à faire une
carrière solo mais j'aime bien
enregistrer des listes j'en enregistre
depuis 15 ans maintenant un peu plus de
15 ans j'aime bien ça la fait quelques
bidons les 70 puis ça a commencé à
marcher avec elle l à 4 800 mille huit
cent mille dix mais je l'ait pas fait
exprès non plus puisque le celui d'après
j'en ai vendu 30 min ça veut rien n'est
fait pour cela il est prêt c'est
beaucoup dire mental on sent que c'est
le subir qua non
jean pierre françois à 7 à survivre